Dan: Get it! Uh!
Oh, my pants.
( laughs )
Oh, my shorts.
Please don't pop.
( music playing )
Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
- Do it again.
- Did it work?
That was about--
- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome to
"The Super Slow Show."
Something I pride
myself on is the ability
to be able to be able to
strike a nice pose,
time a good expression
in slow motion.
You got a lot
of practice.
'cause frequently
I'm filming you and no one's
filming me.
- That's very true.
- Yeah.
Do you remember
the video
when I was in
the giant balloon
and I did the pose?
Gav:
Yeah, the way you've
just been revealed
as like a new superhero.
- Dan: Yeah, a split second.
- Gav: And you looked
like an idiot.
Dan: It's true, it's true,
but in slow mo' it lasted
for ages, yeah.
So, I think you need
a bit of practice.
- Okay.
- So what we should do
is have a pose off.
- Ooh.
- We each get a balloon.
A new challenge,
I like it.
I reckon I've got this.
I'll tell you what,
I always carry,
- a spare giant balloon,
so that's handy, isn't it?
- Oh!
Well, luckily,
there's a fat leaf blower
right here.
Oh! How about that?
I think as reigning
champion you should
probably go first.
- All right.
- So there's something
to work off of.
For sure, you let
the master show you
how it's done, yeah?
All right.
Okay, so this is always
pretty tricky, right?
We'll start with filling
this up a little bit
so I have some air
to breathe.
Yeah, it's actually hard
to get into a balloon
without any air in it.
It's very true.
( leaf blower whirring )
Is that enough
to get in?
I don't know.
Just hand me some.
- Whoa-oh!
- ( laughs )
Ah! It's like blowing
me away.
( laughing )
Get in, get in!
( balloon deflating )
- No, I didn't make it.
- ( laughs )
It's too fat.
My arm's getting crushed,
Ah!
( leaf blower whirring )
- All right, make a seal.
- Okay.
And then you're just
gonna have to go,
shwiver.
What's that?
Do it again.
- Schwiver.
- ( laughs )
Do I have to make
the noise too?
It would help.
Okay, right, if we get
mad in this,
I think it should
probably make a seal.
Okay.
- Yeah, made a seal.
- ( Gav laughs )
- I'm good.
- What am I looking at?
- What is this?
- It's got me choking though.
Gav: All right,
do you need help?
- I'm gonna get an arm in.
- Okay.
- All right?
- Ah! ( laughs )
And I'm gonna need
a bit more leaf blower.
Okay. Ready?
- Hand, uh!
- This one's way easy
to get into.
- ( laughs )
- Jesus.
- Dan: Quick!
- Do you want air in
the front or the back?
Get me in the front.
Uh, the front.
Quick.
Ah, I'm gonna die.
Go!
- ( laughs )
- ( bleep ) do it.
( air blower whirring )
Dan: Okay
I was waiting for
you to tell me to
turn it off--
More air, more air,
quick!
- More air!
- ( laughs )
More air.
Give me some air.
What are you doing?
( laughs )
I'm laughing.
What am I gonna do?
I'm gonna live in here
forever.
But your feet,
your feet...
Okay.
- Oh, my God.
- Dan: Go, go.
- Yeah.
- ( leaf blower whirring )
Oh, oh, hold on.
You know what?
Can I get your little
for inside?
Dan: Hang on a second.
- ( Dan moans )
- Dan, I'm gonna insert
a filming device...
Dan: Okay.
Quick! Before I die again,
quick!
- ( balloon deflating )
- ( Dan screams )
Get some more air,
now.
Okay, you ready?
( laughs )
( air blower whirring )
Both: Oh!
You broke
the selfie stick.
I didn't break it.
Who did?
Well, it was like this.
and then the balloon
crushed me,
and when that is...
sorry.
Uh! Luckily...
- Oh, I just got
another one.
- How convenient.
So, how about that,
right?
( fast forwarding sound )
( leaf blower whirring )
( Dan moaning )
Gav, uh!
Ah! My pants.
Oh, my shorts!
Please don't pop.
- Are you dressed?
- Dan: Yup.
Okay, here we go.
This is it.
( leaf blower whirring )
( popping )
- Dan!
- I wasn't expecting it.
Look for a kneeler.
Went for a--
went for a hero pose,
like a, I don't know,
a power pose.
- All right.
- Like a man power.
But even in slow mo,
I reckon I reacted
that quickly to it.
I was pulling a nice
face and then suddenly
it went like...
Like that,
before it even
popped off.
- Before it popped?
- I reckon it was that quick.
All right, why don't
we take a quick look
at what that
looked like,
just so I know what
I have to beat.
All right.
Dan: I had no idea when
the balloon was going to pop.
Gav:
It got to the height of me.
Dan:
So about four foot then.
Probably-- well,
I'd say more like six,
almost.
( popping )
Gav:
It's sort of Terminator-esque
when you kneel down, isn't it?
Dan: ( laughs ) Yeah.
Gav:
You've just come out
of a ball underneath.
Dan:
Yeah, you see,
I reacted so quick.
Look at the wind.
The lab coat makes it--
Gav:
It actually makes it
look pretty cool,
the floppy cape in the wind.
Dan: Yeah, for sure.
Gav: All right.
- Gav: I think I can
beat that.
- Dan: You reckon?
Yeah, yeah.
I think I got this.
That's what you got.
Get your head in there.
( groans )
How did you do it
so easy?
( laughs )
You gotta commit.
- You gotta commit.
- I'm commit.
Stop moving around.
- ( laughs )
- Just get your head in.
There you go.
( laughs )
Gav: Okay.
This is deeply unpleasant.
Push down the front,
push down the front.
You gotta push down.
( grunts )
Uh!
Oh, okay. Yeah.
They're tugging on
the old shorts.
All right, ah!
Okay.
( laughter )
That's just a balloon.
GoPro, get in there.
All right. Goggles next.
Gav: Yeah.
Thank you.
It's like a post-box
for weird things.
Dan: Pull it.
( grunting )
- Gav: Okay, seal it,
seal it, seal it.
- Dan: Okay.
All right, I'm just
gonna do a bit of, um,
maintenance in here.
I think I much prefer
being outside the balloon.
What are you doing
in there?
Gav:
I'm just doing my buttons up.
Uh, goodness me.
( leaf blower whirring )
( popping )
What the hell?
- What the hell?
- What?
- Did I win?
- I'm not having that!
- What do you mean?
Clearly cheated somehow.
- ( laughs )
- I don't know what--
Is that a martini?
Yeah, appletini.
Let's go watch
the footage.
Gav: Ooh, that one got
a lot bigger.
Dan: Got huge.
( chuckles )
- Probably about eight foot.
- Sort of bean shaped.
Yeah.
( popping )
- ( laughter )
- Dan: No way.
You nailed it!
That's so annoying.
How did you even do that?
Gav: With a smug look .
Dan: Oh, for goodness sake.
Gav: So who wins?
Clearly you've won that,
but you've cheated again.
Ah, you know,
you're always so quick
to use the word cheat.
- What would you call it,
then?
- Creativity.
To be honest with you,
there are no rules,
and then you're always
like, uh, I'll just
cheat and do this,
but there's no rules for getting
into a giant balloon, so...
Gav: Yeah.
( sighs )
Does that mean that
I'm not
the reigning champion
anymore,
and that you've
had one attempt
and you've immediately
beaten me at the only
thing I'm good at.
I think yes, but we'll
make the pose off
a regular thing.
Maybe once every
few years, we'll have
another pose off.
- Yeah.
- Come up with different--
it'll be like--
a dunk contest.
It just gets more
and more ridiculous.
I'm gonna lose sleep
over this.
I'm gonna think about it
so much that you just won't
have a chance next time.
Hopefully, you've enjoyed
our silly pose off.
Feel free to subscribe
to "The Slow Mo Guys"
channel
and we'll see you
in the next episode
of "The Super Slow Show."
Delicious.
( popping )
- ( laughs )
- What the hell?
( music playing )
- Hello, Gave here.
- I'm Dan.
Click here to watch Dan get
slammed by pro wrestlers.
I have no memory of that.
You may have landed
on your head just
a bit.
- Is that why I woke up
in the woods.
- No comment.